hello and welcome to this tutorial I've
actually added this part after I
finished the tutorial course I realize
you may be completely beginner at JSON
web tokens and I didn't talk anything
about what a JWT token is so I'm going
to do that shortly before we start
creating stuff in this tutorial I
recommend you to check out JWT dot io /
introduction on that page they'll
describe everything that you need to
know about JSON web tokens and we can
check out the first part here what is
JSON web token JSON web token is an open
standard that defines the compact
self-contained way for securely
transmitting information between parties
as a JSON object so that's what we're
going to do we're going to build this in
our application and send along a JSON
web token and that is a JSON object and
also this information can be verified
and trusted because it is digitally
signed and the token can be signed using
a secret or you can encrypt it we are
going to use a secret meaning that on
our server part we are going to have a
secret that will sign or JSON web tokens
with so a JSON web token is a JSON
object that we can use to transmit
information between our server and or
application in the client and you can
also read down below here they tell you
why you should use it and when you
should use it in our case we're going to
use it for authentication and
authorization and I think yes they say
this is the most common use case because
when using a JWT token we don't have to
send along or login and password on each
request we can just send the token and
the token can guarantee that it's the
correct user that sends the request so
that's the main advantage of using a
token we don't have to send along the
login and the password on each request
we can just send along the token and we
will know that the user is legit and
they also mention that the overhead is
small and it has the ability to be
easily used across different domains so
that's the main advantages of using a JW
token in your authentication and
authorization system so in our case
we're building this very lightweight
server and from this server
we're also going to generate this token
and send it along to the
and when the user logs in all right we
can continue to scroll down here they
also describe what parts there is in a
JSON web token and you have a header of
payload and the signature and here is
how it looks
first you have the header then you have
a dot and on the payload a dot and a
signature so the header will mostly
contain data about that this is a JWT
and also the signing algorithm for the
token and then we have our payload we
can send along what we want here in our
case we're going to send the user and
we're going to have the email address in
this very very basic example that we're
going to build so the user can log in
and we send along the email address to
the client so the email is going to be
the username in our case but you can put
some other data here also of course in
this case I think they yeah they have
the name and I have if this one is admin
and other stuff here okay and then we
have the last part that's the signature
now we're going to sign or token with a
secret that we set on our server that
way we know that this token is
guaranteed to be generated from our
server because we're always going to
verify that it's signed correctly all
right so I think that's about it that's
a very short introduction to JWT tokens
and we can get started to create our
application and our server I'm going to
talk a little about JSON web tokens and
how you can authenticate your
application with refresh tokens and
access tokens Andrus actually a few good
tutorials out there but they are using a
lot of stuff that you don't need to
understand the concept of JSON web
tokens so my take on this is that I
create a very simple Express server
where we set up our endpoints just
regular rest endpoints and I won't even
use a database we're just going to use a
fake database object for this one so we
won't persist the data cause you don't
need it if you just learning the basics
all right
so nothing fancy in the server in the
backend and I'm just going to use react
for the front-end and when you're going
to fetch the endpoints with no external
library or anything like that so
hopefully this will be a good way for
you to learn about JSON web token
if you're new to the subject and horse I
will say this that I'm not a security
expert I'm mostly front-end developer
but I do some back-end stuff also so
this is not in any way any code you
should use in production and the code
may also be a little bit verbose because
I want to show you all the details on
how this work
my main goal with this tutorial is to
show you how the JSON web token flow
works between the server and your
application and how you can use it it's
not to create a very secure API that you
can use in production alright so let's
get started first of all create the
folder of your choice I call mine JWT
oath and inside of this we're going to
create another folder that's called
server we're going to have two folders
for this one one is the server and one
is for the front so first we set up all
the roads all the restaurant points for
us that we can use in our application
all right and we are going to use
Express for this one
first we have to type NPM in it to the
Creator project and it will give us some
defaults here this one we'll call it JWT
oath and that's fine version is one
description you can have a description
here if you want API server or entry
point it's going to be the index das
file so that's fine and test c'mon we're
not going to do any tests here and get
repository non keywords none you can
just press ENTER here is this okay yes
enter all right so it's created a
package.json file for us and let's go
inside our code editor now we can have a
look at that file and as you can see it
created this stuff for us here alright
then we have to install some packages
we're just going to use Express but
there's some packages that are going to
help us in the creation of our API so we
are going to install something that's
called bcrypt j/s and with this one we
can hash or password because you don't
want to store your password in the
database or in our case a fake database
we have to hash it and also sort it you
can read about bcrypt at this page here
or you can yeah I'm not going to go
through it in detail here then we're
going to install something that's called
cookie parser and this will help us to
get the cookies from the request so what
it will do is to create an object that's
called cookies where we just can grab
our cookie that we're going to use for
the Refresh token then we're going to
install a package that's called course
because we don't want to have any
cross-origin issues here so we're going
to install this and configure it I am
going to use environmental variables for
this one so we install the package dot m
and I'm going to show you this in a
second and of course we have expressed
that we're going to use and then we're
going to create JSON web tokens so we
have a package for this also and lastly
we are going to use something that's
called node mom and this one will yeah
it will make our development a little
bit easier because it will restore the
node server as soon as we make any
changes and we don't have to do that
self manually okay and I'm using postman
to test around points it's free so I
think postman is very good to use for
this all right so let's get back into
our terminal and install these packages
so we type NPM I and we have bcrypt
yes we have our cookie - parser we have
our course or dot n and we have Express
we have a JSON web token and a node 1 is
actually going to be a dev dependencies
who install that one after this one okay
let's take a look inside our code it
install here as we can see that's good
and the node mung we just install it
like a dev dependency here so we have
NPM I knowed mom - - save - dev and it
will install it for us as a dev
dependency okay you can see that it
added it here as a dev dependency and
that's great so that's all that we need
for this API to work and we're going to
start coding it now first we can create
a new file that we call dot n because
we're going to create some environmental
variables here and the first one is
going to be called access underscore
token underscore secret and it's going
to equal you can select whatever you
want here I will of course use Velen
rules yeah okay maybe I should spell
this correctly also to see sin access
okay then we have a refresh on the score
token underscore secret and this one is
going to be wave and rules even more and
then we have the port it's going to be
on port 4,000 all right so we just save
this one then we're going to create a
new folder here that we call SRC and
inside of the SRC we can create a new
file that's called index dot yay
okay so we're going to start importing
some stuff here first of all we're going
to require dot and forward slash config
and this one will make sure that we can
use the environmental variables here
then we create the cost named Express
and we require Express we are not using
es6 imports here because this is node
and this is the standard as you do it in
node you can do it with es6 imports if
you install some packages but we're not
going to do that here so we import
Express then we have our cookie parser
require cookie - parser we have our
course and we have our verify that we're
going to grab from a JSON web token
library and make sure you have these
curly braces here because we're just
importing the verify from that one then
we're going to grab hash and compare
require bcrypt j/s right so that's all
what we need for now we're going to do a
little bit more imports here later on
when we create more files and stuff here
so what are we going to do now we have a
few steps here one we're going to create
an end point where we can register user
two we're going to have an end point for
login the user three we also want to be
able to logout the user for we're going
to set
or protected roads and five get the new
access token with a refresh token and of
course you should have something that
you can revoke the Refresh tokens with
but I'm not going to go through that in
this tutorial because I want to focus on
the most basic stuff here
just to show you how Jason web tokens
work okay first we create our Express
server Const server equals Express
that's the one we imported up here so
that will create the server for us and
then we want to use Express middleware
for easier cookie handling so server dot
use and we call our cookie parser and
this will make sure that we can handle
the cookies a lot more easier then we're
going to set up our course because we
don't want to have issues with that
later server dot use and we have a
course that it's going to take in an
object we have an Origin HTTP colon
forward slash forward slash localhost
and we are going to have our front end
on for 3000 what we're going to use
create react app and that one is default
port 3000 then we're going to set the
credentials to true okay
so this will make sure that our frohnen
and/or server can communicate with each
other then we need to have a couple of
rows here so we can read our body data
and we can actually type out the comment
here needed to be able to read body data
okay grab a server and use and from or
Express we can just call Express JSON
like this and this will make sure that
we support JSON encoded bodies I can
make a quick comment here also to
support JSON and
and coded bodies then server dot use
from Express yet again this is built-in
Express view RL encoded for this one we
send in an object with extended assert
that wanted true and this one supports
URL encoded Boris right
so this is our configuration for our
Express server and we can actually get
it up and running also and then we're
going to create our endpoints and to get
it up and running we can just serve a
dot listen and from our process dot and
we have our environmental variable
called port inside of here so we just
grab this one with this now we have an
inline error function here and we can
just console log out something here
server listening on port this is a
template literals we can just grab
process dot m dot port and we end it
with not a back T and I should of course
removed this one you can save it and
then go inside or a terminal here it I
actually don't have a start script for
this one so we can create this one also
let's go back inside of our package JSON
file and where you see this property
named squits
we can create another one here that's
called start and we are using node moon
for this one as I said this one is going
to make sure that we don't have to
restore the server every time we change
something in our code so we just call or
in
dot J's file here and this is an object
so make sure you have a coma deer also
so we say this one go back inside our
terminal and type M film start and as
you can see it's starting up or so over
here and that's good so we know that
it's working and then we can create our
endpoints and I'm actually going to go
through this quite fast because I think
this course is more focused on a
front-end developer that want to learn
about JSON web tokens and not how to
create the backend itself but I have to
create it here to be able to show you
how the JSON web token and the flow
between the front-end and the server
will work so that's why I created back
in here also and you probably will learn
something about it even if you're not a
back-end developer at all so back into
our code and inside our index dot K is
file so first of all we're going to
create an endpoint for register user so
we have a server and this is going to be
a post request are we going to have
register in our endpoint URL so it's
basically going to be our server that's
localhost and then forward slash
register for this endpoint this one is
going to be async we have our request
and our response and we're going to send
in the email and the password with the
body so we can grab these ones from the
body with the structure them out email
and password from the request body and
we have to do a few things here now
we're going to type our code inside our
try block and then we have our catch
that is going to catch the error for us
so inside over here we're going to do a
lot of stuff first we're going to check
if the user exists and we're going to do
that from our faith database but I want
to populate the fake database with a
user so I'm going to need a hashed
passed
for that one so that's why I'm going to
create a hash password and console.log
it out and then I can just copy and
paste it inside of my fake database that
I'm going to create so Const hash
password we await hash and we have our
password that's the one we got up here
and we going to sort it and this is how
many times you want to calculate the
salt so I think ten times maybe
something like that so this will give us
a hash password and we can console log
this out and save it and to start up the
server again and I'm going to go inside
of postman now and use that one so I
have this endpoint that's called
register and I actually have it appear
on our local host and port 4000 we have
the register endpoint and I've attached
an email and a password to the body so
well send this one hopefully it will
come so log out
perhaps password for us and it did so
I'm just going to grab this one from the
console copy it go back inside of my
code create a new file inside of the
source folder here and call it fake
dbaas then I'm going to export fake DB
and it's going to be an array that's
going to have different objects with the
different users so we create an object
we set the ID to zero the email is going
to be my mail you can of course use your
own here like this and then we have the
password and inside of the string are
just pasting in this password can also
make a note here the password is test so
this is a fake database that we're going
to use
sale is one can go back inside over
index.js file and we can finish this
register and point so first of all we're
going to check if the user exists Combs
user from the fake DB of course we also
have to import it up here so Const fake
DB equals require now we grab it from
dot forward slash fake DB dot J s ok in
our fake DB this is just an array so you
can just use the array method find and
we have our user we check if our user
email equals or email so we check if
this email exists in our database and
this one here is the one that we got
from the body and of course in the real
world here you should do some connection
to real database and check for that
there so this is a fake DB this is just
an array with JavaScript objects but
you're going to use a real database here
in the real world in production but for
now this will do for us okay then if we
have a user we're actually going to
throw an error here because if we user
exists we shouldn't be able to register
a new user with the same email so we
throw new error user already exists if
not user exists hash the password and
we've already done that here so you
don't have to do that again we have it
stored in the hash password Const so
three insert the user in and I'm going
to put this inside of quotes because
this is not a database this is just a
fake database but you insert the user in
your database and we can just push the
user inside the fake DB array fake DB
push we create an object we have an ID
fake DB dot length the length is always
going to be larger than the index so
that's why we can use the length here
because if we have one post in our
database as we have now this is the
index 0 but the length is going to be 1
so that's why we can use the length here
then we have our email and we have our
password and this one is going to be the
hashed password and we have a coma dear
of course okay so we have stored the
user in the database so we can send back
a response to the client rest sound and
we have an object with a message of
user-created life so instead of console
log out the hash password here we can
actually console log out the fake DB
all right then we also have to catch if
we have some arrows so we send back the
response with an error and we just send
the error message error dot message all
right and do a little bit of order
formatting there so this should be it
for the register endpoint so we try it
out in postman and I created this once
no so I have to actually kill the server
now I start it again because I want to
clean up my fake database so I go back
in postman I put the email and the
password in the body that's my email
address with a three and was to the test
as password so I send this one used to
create it that's great and as you can
see we are console logging out the
database we have two uses here now and
that's great go back inside of postman
and try to register the exact same user
and it tells me that the user already
exists and that's great
so we can't register the same user twice
so we know that it's working
that's a register endpoint now we're
going to create our login endpoint yeah
and I should of course move this one to
the bottom like this login a user right
yet again we have a server dot post we
create a post request and it's going to
be log in we have an async inline
function here we have the request and
the response and on error function and
yet again from our body we want to grab
our email and our password so we
destructor them out from our request
stop body then we have a try and the
catch with the error like so and inside
the try block we're going to type out
our code so first find user in array or
in or in database if not exist some
error right Const user fake DB not find
this is the exact same step as we did
before so just check if the user email
equals the email and now check if not
you sir if we don't have a user throw
new error user does not exist right so
if we don't have a user we cannot login
to compare cryptid password and see if
it checks out some error if not so
create
cause that's called valid we have wait
and we have this compare function from
the bcrypt library 3 compare or password
that's the one we got up here from the
body and now we have a password stored
in our database from the user of
password so we compare these two and see
if they are the same so if not valid
throw new error password not correct so
if it not checks out we just send an
error and tell the user that the
password is wrong but if it's correct we
can create a refresh and access token
like this and the ID today is to have a
refresh token and an access token your
access token should have a really short
lifetime and the Refresh token should
have a longer lifetime and stored for
example as a protected cookie that you
cannot use from inside of the JavaScript
in your client we're going to create two
tokens 1 refresh and 1 access token
first we have our access token
am I going to have to create this
somehow and we have a refresh token that
we also need to create somehow and we're
actually going to create a new file here
just call it tokens dot yes and inside
of this file we first import sign
require we require it from JSON web
token then we create the function here
create access token we're going to send
in the user ID as a parameter and from
this one we're going to return something
and we're going to return sign we call
that sign that we imported up here we
give it an object with the user ID and
then from our process dot on dot access
underscore
token secret so we sign it with that
secret and we also include our user ID
then we have an object where we could
set the expire time expires in and for
this one we're going to set the 15
minutes so this is how we create the
access token we can just copy this one
and paste it in and we can rename it to
create refresh token and we change this
one to refresh underscore token
underscore secret and it expires in
seven days that's a week okay and for
now we just module export and we export
our trade access token and or create
refresh token so we can use them in our
index.js file so of course we have to
import them up here at the top first
Const create access token and create
refresh token require and it's going to
be from dot forward slash tokens IAS all
right we're good to go we can use these
ones inside of this file now so first we
create an access token great access
token with sending the user dot ID
that's the one that we got from the
database and here we create the refresh
token and we also send in the user dot
ID and in the real world in the real
life you could also create different
versions of the refresh token and store
it in your database or just store a
version number if you don't want to
store the complete refresh token and you
can compare it you can sign it as we do
here you can also sign it here with the
test access token the refresh token you
can have a version number here and then
you can check the
version number and when you revoke the
refresh token you just increase the
version number and that way that token
could never be used again but for the
sake of the simplicity of this tutorial
I'm not going to do anything of this
I've just created one refresh token so
if you want to make some function to
revoke it you just can delete this one
from the fake DB but keep in mind that
you can have different versions of
refresh tokens so for now put the
refresh token in the database and we
already have our user here so we can
just mutate this one we create a new
property that's called refresh token and
we just give it to refresh token so we
save that one inside of the database
there and if we want we can also
console.log out the fake DB here so we
can see that this actually gets created
alright so we have our access token and
a refresh token created that we have to
send them to the client somehow it's a
five-cent token refresh token acid
cookie and access token as a regular
response right and we're going back
inside over Tokyo's jeaious because I'm
going to create two functions for us
that is going to handle the sound of the
tokens so just below here we create
another function send access token now
we have the response to request and the
access token and we just do a response
sound you could of course do this inside
of the index file also but I've did this
too yeah kind of structure it a little
bit so we send the access token and we
can also yeah we can send the email also
from the request body dot email
right and then we have a Const sound
refresh token for this one we're going
to have the response and the token we
can call it refresh token all right and
for this one we're setting a cookie
instead we don't want to send it with a
regular response so we our rest cookie
we're going to call the cookie refresh
token you can of course call it
something more secret because now you
can just check the cookie and see that
this is a refresh token but I do it like
this
so we easily can track this token that's
why then we have our token and we have
an object we're going to set it to HTTP
only and this make sure that we can't
access this cookie from our client you
can't modify the cookie with JavaScript
and we're also going to set a path
because we don't want to send this
cookie along with each request we just
do it when we're on the refresh on this
Court opium endpoint this is the end
point we're going to use when we want to
get a new access token with or refresh
token and I'm going to come back to that
later all right we also have to export
this once send access token and send
refresh token like this so that's all
for our tokens dot J's file let's go
back inside of index dot JSON user
function here of course we first have to
import them up here so we import send
access token and send refresh token all
right now we can go back inside of this
one here yes below here we first send a
refresh token we have the response and
refresh token itself and then we call
send access token we have the rest
once the request and the access token
maybe this should be the other way
around here maybe have to request first
on the response as the second parameter
but yeah
hey it's like this now okay all right so
that's it we just have to catch any
errors if we get that here so we're
rests and just as we did before we have
an object and an error message back
ticks
it's a template literal we grab the
error message and end it with a back
tick like this
all of you married and save it so we can
go back inside of postman and we can try
to log in here as you can see in the
body I send the email and the password
so we try to send it okay we have some
error here create access token is not a
function all right yeah I know what it
should be
exports here not export so make sure you
have an S there also if you also miss
that one save it and go back inside of
postman and we try this again now we
have another error here token is not
defined all right yeah of course I
rename this one here inside of tokyo's
yes it should be refresh token and save
this one I actually called it token
first but I changed it now when I record
this to refresh token cuz it makes more
sense so it should be refresh token and
back again inside of postman we try it
again and as you can see we get an
access token back and we also get our
email back and did we get something
inside of the database yeah you can see
icon so logged out the database here and
the Refresh token has been created and
it's now in the database so we can try
to register a new user here I have this
one with a three in my email so I just
create a user and as you can see
one is created but it don't have a
refresh token no we haven't logged in
and got the Refresh token so it seems to
be working now that's great so let's get
on with it
we also want to be able to log out the
user 3 log out a user this one is going
to be C we have the server dot post and
we're going to have log out as the
endpoint we have the request will not
continues that one so I mark it with
this underscore and we have the response
so when we log out we just clear the
cookie rest clear cookie and we call it
refresh token that will make sure that
we wipe out the Refresh token from the
cookie and we also have to clear the
access token from the client of course
when we log out but with no refresh
token we can't get a new access token
before we login and then we just return
the response not send and a message
logged out that's or log out then number
4 we are going to create a protected
route just to show you an example of how
you can do this authorization with the
token so we have served on post we can
just call it forward slash protected
this is an async function so we mark it
with async and we have the request the
response and an inline error function
then we try we catch the error now we
have a Const
user ID is off now we send in the
request we are going to create this one
now so we create a new file inside of
this source that's the last file we're
going to create here we call it is oath
doc yes and first we are going to import
verify we require it from JSON web token
and that's the way we can verify the
token that we have in our header then we
create the function called is auth we
have the request an error function Const
authorization and from our request and
the headers we are going to grab the one
that's called authorization and this
will give us our token if we don't have
any token if not authorization then we
throw new error you need to login
because if we're not sending a token we
know that the user isn't logged in so
that's why we can throw this error and
tell them that they need to login
otherwise we can get the token
so from authorization we split that one
like this and we grab from index one in
the array and this is because the
authorization in the header is going to
look something like this
beer and then you have the token in here
this is a string so we just strip out
beer and we just grab this one and
that's what we're doing here so that's
how we get to token so this is a
standard as you use beer and then have
the token after that word
that's called beer err yeah that's very
difficult for me to say because I'm not
used to that smooth ours are are yeah
you know it's it's tough to be from
Sweden and try to speak English alright
so we have our tokens then we're going
to grab our user ID and we get it from
verified and that's from JSON web token
we have our token and we verify it with
the process dot M
not access underscore token secret
so this way we make sure that this is a
legit token and then we just return the
user ID okay
module dot exports equals is oath or you
could of course just export it as we did
with the fake DB exports dot faith DB
instead if you want to do that right
back inside of index we need to import
is oath Const is off equals required dot
forward slash is oath yes and now we can
use it here this is getting a little bit
messy here I I know that as I said the
code is going to be a bit verbose and
there's a lot of code here maybe but I
think it's necessary to fully understand
something when explaining advanced stuff
like this if the user ID doesn't equal
no and that's because we could just do
it like this but that will give us a
false answer if the ID is zero so that's
why I'm doing this we have rests and the
data you can just type this is protected
data all right and then inside of catch
just as before rests and we send an
error message like so so we save this
one and we can see if the protected
route works then login again protected
and as you can see in the author
sation here we can just grab the access
token that we get here and this is
actually an old token also it shouldn't
work now it says that you need to login
so if I just paste in a new token here
it hopefully should work and it doesn't
all right yeah and of course I can see
now I forgot an S here it should be
headers it's very easy to forget
something like that so I save it and
then we can try it again yes you can see
this is protected data so now we're
accessing it with our token and that's
great really really easy to do something
stupid like this and forget on s I hope
you didn't do that that's the second
time in this tutorial I did something
like this right I have to slap myself in
the face cuz I'm not bad at typing this
stuff out right back inside of index we
know that this one is working and we
just have one more route to create and
then our API will be finished and that's
the route for getting a new access token
so 5 get a new access token with a
refresh token all right
we have server dot post forward slash
refresh underscore token we have our
requests and our response and an inline
error function we have our token and now
we can just grab it from the request
cookies refresh token that's why we
install the library that's called cookie
parser and if we don't have a token in
our request if not token return response
dot Sam
the access token we just clear it out so
we just send an empty access token you
could also send a message here also to
the kind of course otherwise we have a
token let's verify it so we left we
create payload and we set that one to
node for starters and we have a try
and the catch with the error inside our
try we set the payload we're going to
verify we have the token that's the one
that we grabbed from the cookies and we
have our process dot m dot refresh token
refresh underscore token underscore
secret we verify that our token is legit
otherwise return response dots and yet
again we just send an empty access token
we know that the token is valid so check
if user exists Const user we go inside
or fake DB and find user we check if our
user ID equals to the payload ID the
payload user ID because we signed or
token with the user ID we get that one
when we verify it if this verify it will
give us the ID so we can just compare
this one with one in the database and
see if it exists there the lid it should
say if not user returned response and
yet again we send an empty access token
because the user didn't exist in the
database user exists
check if refresh token exists
on you sir if you sir got refresh token
not equals token if we have another
token registered to the user we don't
want to send a new access token so we
just return response and have a set
access token to an empty string again
whoa there's many steps here where will
token exist create new refresh and
access token
so again we create our access token
create access token sundean or user ID
as you can see here this is repetitive
code we did this up here before so as I
told you before this code is very
verbose you can refactor it to make it
more effective and look a lot more
cleaner but it's good to have it here
now so easily can understand every step
and how this works then we create the
refresh token also with the user dot ID
then we need to update the refresh token
in the database and as I also told you
before you could have different versions
here instead of the Refresh token but I
will just grab the user and refresh
token and mutate this property here with
a new refresh token so this will update
it in our temporary database object all
good to go send new refresh token and
access token so we send the Refresh
token we have the response and the
refresh token and then we return rest
and and the access token whoa that was a
lot but hopefully you'll understand all
the steps needed here and
you can also see that you need to have
some connection to a real database and
uses that you saved somewhere because
this is just fake so let's save this one
see if it works no errors that's good we
can try this out now first of all we can
log in we have the refresh token so we
try this and as you can see we get a new
access token back that's because our
refresh token is saved in is saved in
the cookies I think we should be able to
see it somewhere yeah here you can see
the refresh token that is being sent but
we won't be able to grab it in or
JavaScript from the client and then if
we log out like this we shouldn't be
able to get a new access token
obviously it has not cleared it from
here yeah and I think I know what's
wrong we have to set the path here also
it has to have the same path refresh on
the score token like this because we
told it to just send this cookie on this
path so when we clear it we just make
sure to include this path here also so I
save this one and go back inside of
postman and hopefully this will work now
I'll log out yeah and as you can see it
won't give us an access token now and
then we can also try out we try to login
then a new cookie should be set so
icarly is right again and as you can see
we get a new access token so it's
working now make sure that you include
path here otherwise it won't work all
right so that concludes the server in
the next part we're going to create the
front-end with react and use this API
hey this is the second part in this
tutorial and we're going to build a frog
on in this one and as you can see I'm
inside a JWT oath folder now that I
created in the last part and I also have
this server folder and I hope you didn't
made the same mistake as I did because I
didn't navigate inside of this folder
when I created API so I had to move all
the files manually inside of the server
folder so i navigate inside of that one
and all our files are here for the api
and also we can open up the code it can
always be good to have it here if
there's something that we need to change
in our api and actually I had this typo
again I had forgotten I in the origin in
the course in the index doc jeaious file
hope you didn't do that mistake also so
make sure that it says origin here
otherwise it won't work okay so back
inside of the terminal we can just mm
start them fire up our server then I
have another tab here in my console and
I'm going to create a react application
for a front-end now I assume that you
know react I'm not going to teach you
react or CSS or anything in this course
I'm just going to very quickly create
this little application that we can use
to communicate with our server to get
our JSON web tokens and show you how
JSON web tokens work alright we're going
to create this application with create
react app so we type MPX create - react
- app and we're going to call it from
them and this will create a folder here
that's called frohnen and it's going to
put all the code inside of that one so
just have to wait a little bit now so
that's it we navigate inside the
front-end folder and open up our code
editor so this
what we've got here we have a
package.json it's installed everything
for us and we also have this SRC folder
with different components that it's
created for us and we can actually
remove some of them here we can remove
the service worker we can remove the
logo you can remove the app test and the
app dot CSS we're going to create some
CSS in this index dot CSS file and we
also have to go inside index J s so we
remove the serviceworker
and remove all this stuff here and just
save it and inside our FJ s remove the
app dot CSS import and the import of the
logo and for now we can just remove
everything on this and let's type out
app and then we can go back inside our
console
now we're going to install two
dependencies so npm i we're going to
need the reach router for this one at
reach forward slash router and also i
think we're going to need a es lint
- plugin - react - cooks and while this
installs i can grab some coffee here
that's always a good idea and as you can
see I'm getting this errors here they
started to appear just recently I think
it is because I'm using both yarn and
NPM they create react app create the app
with yarn and now I'm using NPM but I'm
going to show you how to get rid of
these if you get these errors - just
wait for it to finish here so what you
can do is you go inside of your code
just remove the node modules folder and
also the package lock file and go in
terminal and thought mmm install I
haven't got time enough to dive deep in
this and see what's causing this so I
don't really know actually but I know
that this works so that's it we can try
and perm start and we navigate to
localhost 3000 and as you can see we're
showing up here so we know that it's
working that's good so back inside our
code editor and we're going to create a
new folder here inside our SRC folder
create a new folder named components and
we're going to scaffold out five
components we have one that's called
content doc yes one that's called login
DoDEA's and navigation doc yes protected
doctor yes and register yes we can just
careful out them now and we'll come back
to them later so we import react from
reacts we create a functional component
called content equals and an error
function and for now we just return a
div that says content and we export
default content all right we can just
copy this one now make sure you save it
also of course and go inside the login
and we change this content to login and
save it move on to the navigation change
content to navigation save it and inside
protected the same thing protected and
register
register so this is just the scaffolding
of this we'll come back to them later
and I can also say that this application
will also be a bit verbose in the code
and has a maybe a lot of redundant code
for example the login and the register
component will have almost the same code
inside of them that's actually
intentionally because I think that I
will make this as easy as possible for
you but this is not in any way just as
with the API of production finished
application we just training it in
educational purpose so bear with me with
that one okay and we have to create some
CSS for this one also so we can do that
right now when we are added so inside of
the index dot CSS file we have this body
we can actually remove this code and up
here we can add the background and it's
going to be still blue just keep
everything else here doesn't really
matter then we have the dot F class and
with text a line we set at the center we
set a min height of 100 viewport height
we display flex we set the Flex
Direction to column we align items
Center and also justify content to
Center we set the color to white
FFF and the font size to 16 pixels okay
then we have a class that's called login
- wrapper we set the mean height to 200
pixels we set the mean width to 300
pixels we set the background to white
the parent to 20 pixels the border -
- five pixels and light blue and solid
we set the color to black zero zero zero
okay that's our login wrapper and we are
of course going to use these classes in
our components in a production app I
would use style components but in this
case we're just importing a regular CSS
file and yeah that's not good to do it
like that but it it'll work for us in
this application then we have dot log in
- input and we're going to have a button
in that one so we set the background on
the button to light blue we
display:block we set the width to
hundred percent the heart 250 pixels
yeah and that's it for that one then on
the same class login - input we're going
to have our input fields and we can
display block we set the padding to 20
pixels the width is going to be
hundred-percent the height is going to
be 50 pixels and Morgan 10 pixels 0 we
set the box icing to border-box okay
just a few more we have to start or
unordered list that we're going to have
for our navigation so we have our ul
list - style - type we set at one to
none except Morgan to 40 pixels auto we
set the width to 300 pixels and the
padding to zero then we have the UL li
elements we display inline
- block and set the Morgan to 10 pixels
right
on the last one and that's the link
that's the a tag we set the color to
white
FFF and text-decoration:none so that's
our CSS and we can already see that it's
changing here and that's good okay we
can move inside our FPS file now and
we're going to create this one first
we're going to add some imports here
we're going to use state and also use
effect for this one and then we import
router and navigate from at reach router
okay then we import all our components
so we import navigation from dot forward
slash components forward slash
navigation we can just copy this one
paste it in four times we change these
ones here this one is going to be the
login this one register protected as you
can see I'm changing it in two places at
the same time here so make sure you also
change the path here and the last one is
going to be her content all right so
that's our component then we're going to
create a context that we're going to use
for yeah almost like a global state here
by creating a context we can access the
state inside of all our components in
the application so we export Chrome's
user context and react dot create
context and for now it can just be an
empty array so that is going to be our
context and inside our app components we
are going to create some local state
first we have a Const with our user and
set user that is going to hold our
access token so you stayed
and it's going to be an empty object for
now let me create another one loading
and set loading and you stay and we set
that one to true because when this
application run we're going to have a
use effect that will fire off and send
or refreshed opium to get a new access
token if we have a refresh token so that
way we don't have to login yeah in a
production app you wouldn't do it this
way you probably will have a library for
example a polar or something that will
handle this for you when you have a real
database to connect to but for now to
this tutorial as I said I will do this
as simple as possible so we're just
using the thing we got in react and
we're going to grab it with the use
effect we're also going to have a couple
of functions in this one so we have
const log out fullback and this one is
obviously going to be for our log out
button and it's going to be a sync and
we leave it empty for now then we're
going to have our use effect and that
one is also going to be empty for now to
give it an empty array here also as a
dependency so then we can create our JSX
for this one so we have this div with
the class name of app we're going to
wrap it with our context so we have our
use of context dot provider and the
value is going to be on array with our
user and set user so this is the way we
can pass this state down to all our
components you close it remove this one
inside of that one
alright then we have our app then we're
going to have our navigation the
navigation is going to have a logout
callback logout callback so this is a
prop so we send in our logout callback
function so that one then we're going
router we're going to change routes here
depending on what page you're on so we
have an ID of router and then we just
have our components here we have a login
component that's going to have a past of
login then we have our register that's
going to have a path of register and or
protected that has the path of protected
oops
it should self closed like this and then
we have our content and this one is
going to have the path of a forward
slash because that's our main landing
page that's our homepage and I think
this is it for this component actually
for now of course we're going to fill
this out with more code later but we can
save it and see what we've got so button
navigation and content here and that's
great so we can actually create our
navigation now so make sure your
navigate inside of your navigation dot
JS file so we're already importing react
we're also going to import link from at
reach router okay then we got our
navigation here we're going to the
structure out or prop or logout callback
and here we create parentheses and as
you can remove this one because you're
going to have an unordered list here and
then we create our menu items so we have
a li element we have a link and it's
going to link to the forward slash
that's our homepage
so we name it home and we can actually
copy this one and paste it in three
times and this link is going to go to
protected and we type our protector and
this one is going to go to red
stir and register and the last one is
not going to have a link actually it
can't have a button so we have a button
with an onclick handler that's going to
be or prop logout callback and we can
just type up logout so this is it for a
navigation we save this one and see what
we've got
yeah we have our navigation here and as
you can see it changed rocks here and
that's good and it also change component
here so our navigation is working and or
routing is working that's nice okay
so we can move on to create our content
component so inside the content of J's
file up here we also go into import use
context that's a hook that we'll use to
grab our context then we import a
component that's named redirect from at
reach router and we also import our user
context to grab that from dot dot
forward slash and it's in or F right now
we have our content component we can
remove this one and create curly braces
because inside of here we're going to
check it for context if our stayed in
the context the user contain our access
token so we can grab that one first
Const user we use context that's the
context hook that we imported up here
and we send in or use the context and
this will give us our user so if we not
have a user dot access token we just
return and we have the redirect
component from the rich rural library
from we set that one to an empty string
too and we're going to redirect them to
the login code if we don't have an
access token we want them to login and
we don't want to show the content here
and we can also have no throw like this
otherwise if
have an access token we return a div and
here we can have our content so this is
the contents okay so this is it if
you're using something like as I said a
polar or something you should have that
one to check if the access token has
expired or not or and if it has expired
you can automatically in the background
grab a new access token if you still
have a valid refresh token but I won't
go through that here I'm not doing that
here so if the access token expire it
won't grab a new one
from the Refresh token endpoint
automatically okay we'll save it and we
can go to our start page and as you can
see it's showing us the login page
we don't have an access token so that's
why it's redirecting us to the login
page and that's great so we can actually
create our login page now to make sure
you in the login is file up here we're
going to import the more stuff from
react because the you stayed use context
and use effect and we also going to
import navigate from a tweet router and
we import our user context from dot
forward slash app alright and then we
have our component here we can remove
this one and create color braces first
we grab our context comes user and set
user equals use context and we send in
our user context then we're going to
have two local states for this one it's
going to be one for the email and one
for the password that's the input fields
that we're going to have in this one
sorry create a Const email and set email
you stay and it's going to be an empty
string for now and then we have the
password and set password equals you
stayed and an empty string like so then
we're going to
two functions in this one we're going to
have one that call and I'll submit and
it's obviously going to handle the
submit of the form it's going to be
async and we have the event and an error
function and we leave it empty for now
then we're going to have one that's
called handles change and this one is
going to be when we type something in
the input boxes and we have the event
and an error function for this one also
so we can start typing out or JSX that
we're going to return for this one so
return parentheses we have a div with
the class name of login - wrapper we
have or form that is going to have an
own submit and we just call or handle
submit function on that one and inside
our form we're going to have our input
fields but first we're going to have a
div with a header or maybe yeah can
actually have an h2 tag that says login
and then we have an input it's going to
have a value we grab that from our state
email this is going to be a control
component so unchanged we call our
handles change it's going to be the type
text' name is going to be emailed the
place holder is going to be email and i
think we need to have something that's
called autocomplete email and we can
copy all of this and paste it in below
all of these we change the password
place or maybe a capital P and this one
I think should say parent - password so
make sure you change all of these here
then we of course need us
meet button so below here we create a
button type submit' and it can say login
yeah yeah we also have to wrap these
inputs in a div that's called class name
login
- input so move this everything here
inside of this div something like this
the order for Mary isn't working here
now for me so I have to do it manually
ok we save that one and we can see what
we've got so far yeah this one shouldn't
be all the way out to the areas I don't
know why we look into that later okay so
let's get back inside over login dot J's
file so first we have these handles
change because when we type something
here it doesn't show anything now at all
so we have to hook this up to our states
will show the values so we have these
handles change
we got the event here so we can just
check if the event dot current targets
the name equals email then we can set
email a dot current targets dot value
right we just have two input fields in
this one so we can just make an else
here we know that otherwise it's the set
password we should call a dot current
target dot value so we save this one and
we can see if it works and as you can
see we can type something here now and
that's great it works alright then we
have our handle submit and this one is
going to do all the job for us to grab
the token from our API so the first
thing
have to do inside of here is to prevent
the fault we don't want to send the form
because we want to handle this ourselves
then we have Const result we're going to
await and we await again we fetch from
HTTP colon forward slash forward slash
localhost and our server is at port 4000
and we're going to hit the endpoint
login then we have a coma and an object
because we need to send in some stuff
here also we set the method to post you
set credentials to include then we have
our headers and our headers is going to
be content - type application forward
slash JSON all right so we're setting
the type of our headers here and then we
have our body and that is going to be
json dot stringify we have to make it a
string and we have our email actually as
it's the same here we can just type out
email and the same with password and
here we have dot JSON we call that one
that's why we await two times here first
we await the fetch and then we await
when we convert it to JSON so that will
give us the result in this comes here
so if result dot access token if we got
an access token we can set the user so
we set the access token and we grab that
from the result dot access token then
when we have set the access token we
want to navigate back to the home page
else if we don't got an access token we
can just console log the result dot
error
all right and if we want we can also
create the use effect here when the
users change we create a dependency
array with the user and we can just
console.log out the user so we see
what's change inside of that one alright
so we save this one and we can try it
out so let's go to our application and
inspect I want to look in the console we
reload it you can see we have an empty
object here to start with because we
console log out or use the state or
access token state we can try to log in
here then you can see we console log out
the error here and it tells us that we
not sent along a valid password and my
password is going to be test and as you
can see we got the access token here and
now we redirected to the start page and
it's showing us the contents so that's
good but we're not grabbing a new access
token now as you can see here so it will
wipe out the state every time we reload
this but we'll fix this later
so we store the access token in our
state in the application we're not
storing it in local storage or anything
like that
we're just having it in our application
and the refresh token is being sent to
the client as a protected cookie so we
can't really do anything with that
cookie with our JavaScript code so back
inside our code and we can actually go
inside of the app dot J's file and in or
use effect here I can make some comment
first thing get a new access token if a
refresh token exists right so inside a
reduce effect we're going to create an
async function
refresh token so we get the
enhanced result and we await and we
await again fetch and this time we're
going to hit our endpoint for a refresh
token so localhost port four thousand
four slash refresh underscore token coma
and we have an object here method post
credentials this one has to be include
otherwise the cookie won't be included
and it won't work so needed to include
the cookie we have our headers we set
the content type to application /j so I
actually think that this is the default
but it won't hurt to have it here and
then here dot JSON so we can set the
user the access token we grabbed it from
result access token so this will set it
in either case because either we got an
empty access token or we got the access
token so it will set it to an empty
string or we set it to the actual access
token that we got then we can set the
loading to false right and just below
here we cool this check refresh token
and we have to do it like this because
you can't have an async use effect so
you just create an async function inside
of the use effect and call it like this
and this means that it will just fire
off this when we mount the application
so this will just run one time and we
can actually before we return or JSX we
can actually check if loading then we
just
turn the div we return a div that says
loading so we save this one I can try it
out as you can see here now as I reload
the page you can see that it loading
flashes here so it grabs the new access
token from a refresh token endpoint so
that's good
we don't have to login as long as we
have a valid refresh token so that's how
a refresh token work as long as it's
valid you can just call that endpoint
with the refresh token and it will send
back a valid access token for you to use
in your application so that's very
convenient to have that one and don't
need to login every time then we can
create our logout function here as we're
in this component now so we have this
logout callback this one we can just
await fetch and from our local host port
4000 we have this endpoint that's called
logout and we set a method to post and
we can also include the credentials like
so then this will wipe out the cookie
but we also want to reset our
application on the front-end clear user
from context set user and we just give
it an empty object for this one and then
we also want to navigate back to start
page so new navigate and forward slash
right we save it and we can see if it
works will log out and you can see we go
to the start page you can see that it
redirect us to the login that means that
we don't have a refresh token now
because we logged out so we login again
and it's showing us the content and
that's great
and if we reload it it will grab a new
access token as long as we don't log out
but if we log out it wipe out the
Refresh token so we have to login again
all right great it works you can also
see here in the console log that the
access token is just an empty string
okay we can create the register
component also and we can actually just
copy all the code from the login
component and paste it in the register
component of course we're going to
rename this to register and also export
default register we have to change a few
things here now we're not going to need
a context for this one for the use
effect just use stale so we can delete
these ones here and delete the context
we are going to use the email and the
password local state this one we change
this to register so we hit the register
endpoint instead the method is going to
be post credentials yeah we can try it
we don't need to include the credentials
here because we won't send along the
cookie the headers can stay the same the
body the same everything is the same
here and we're not setting a user here
so we can just remove this one and if
result of error we can just console
aughh we want to know this error so
consular result message no this is
actually if we don't have an error so we
just can console log out the message we
get back and then we want to navigate to
the front page to the home page else
then we come to logout the result of
error alright we can remove the use
affect the
and this change is going to be the same
and we can change this one to register
instead everything else is going to be
the same yeah and also this one here
should say register and we save it we
can see if it works
so we go to the register and you can see
it changes here it's the exact same
otherwise but we just changed these ones
here we can just try to register without
the user as you can see we can now
create this is a bug here actually we
can create an empty user and that
shouldn't be possible so we have to
check that in our API also of course but
not for this tutorial okay so we just
created an empty user and we can see in
our console if we go to our or API here
you can see that we created this one we
don't empty email and this password that
gets generated is from an empty string
and that's no good of course but if we
try to create a user that's the same as
already in the database it should warn
us yeah user already exists and it
doesn't matter if we write another
password here or something but we can
create maybe put a two there and we
register and you can see the user is
created and we console.log it out here
so we can see that it gets traded and
it's put in the database that's not a
database that's or fake database maybe
you should get login automatically when
you create a user and we're actually
logged in as a not user now because yeah
this is not a production app and I just
want to show you how this stuff works
now so yeah we just created the user but
we logged in as another user and that's
no good of course but it works we can
register user and we can login and we
can logout so if we login with the new
user we created you can see first yeah
it's just that the password is not
correct and I had a same password we can
login with
user instead so that's great okay it's
working so this is how the flow is when
you send tokens to your client until
your API and yeah it's very convenient
that you don't have to login all the
time and you can just have these tokens
that will simplify everything for you
that will simplify everything for your
juicer it's not simple to do this stuff
actually ok so we have one more thing to
do we have to create a protected road to
show you how you can protect data and
use your token to get that data yeah and
I just realized why our CSS isn't
working as it should and that's because
if we move inside of the apt of J's file
the class name is a capital A here and
app just change that one to a lowercase
a and save it and it should work yeah
it's a little bit nice to know you can
see looks more like a regular login form
now and yeah it's centered and the nice
stuff like that so yeah that's great
move back inside of the protected KS
file for this one we are going to need
the use affect the youth stayed and use
context we're also going to import the
user context from dot dot forward slash
app and we can remove this one and
create curly braces so we have the Const
user and we use context and send in our
user context then recreate a local state
content and set content you stayed and
we give it
initial string of you need to login and
of course there's many ways of doing
this so this is just one way to show you
a simple solution how we can get the
protected data and show it in our
component then we're going to have a use
effect and this one is going to fire off
when the user changes so we create an
async function that's called fetch
protected we have yet again the const or
result we await and we await again the
fetch and from our local host forward
slash protected we are going to grab our
data we have a method of post the
headers are going to be content - type
application forward slash JSON then we
have authorization this is really
important here we send along this
property here that's called
authorization we give it a string we
have backticks here now with a beer and
then we give it the user access token
and it will back T so this is the
standard of sending your access token
you have this beer in front of the
access token so that's what we stripped
away in our API when we get to access
token and we actually can look at it
here up here you see we get the token by
splitting authorization and we get an
array with the values and the value at
the index one is going to be our access
token so we removed
this way were the bearer beer-beer yeah
I really don't know how you pronounce
that yeah so yeah it may be wrong but I
hope you understand what I mean so
that's how we stand along the access
token and down below here we just
convert it to Jason and then if result
data if we get some data back we set the
content with result of data and here we
have to call or fetch protected down
below here we just returned a div with
the content so obviously this is not
going to change if you don't get any
data we just displaying you need to
login otherwise we display the data we
get back so we can save this one now and
see if it works now you see we could
look in now with not a user or a
password because we created a completely
empty user and you shouldn't be able to
do that but we login now and we can see
if the protected words no it doesn't
work actually so we have to figure out
why yeah and I'd done it again I can see
here now there should be an S near I
missed that again I think that's the
third or fourth time in this tutorial as
it's really easy to do something like
this especially when you see there and
record everything and are going to show
you this stuff so yeah make sure you
have an S on the headers so I try to log
in and I go
the protected roads and it says this is
protected data so that's good that's
fine it was just that little s that
messed everything up here that's the
beauty of coding one little small typo
can ruin everything for you so as you
can see we're getting the protected data
cause we send along the access token
here so that's how you protect data with
your API and you need a user to send
along the access token to get the data
so this is it actually maybe it seems a
little bit much and yeah it is
authorization and authentication is
really advanced stuff so it should be a
lot I think I actually find it a bit
hard to explain also because it's a very
advanced topic and I hope you learned
something from it I will appreciate if
you want to subscribe to my youtube
channel and you can also add me at
twitter at Valen fart I also got a few
premium courses in react out there there
on my own platform WWE Beam fark.com and
I have a few on udemy also no but I'm
going to move them to my own platform in
the future so hope you enjoyed it
sealing another one